How many Muslims are there in the world?
>> They like to rape little girls. That's
normal That's normal in Islam.
>> are there? How many Muslims? How many
Muslims? So she keeps talking about the
idea She keeps talking about this idea
of rapists and the like. Piers, I went
to the uh the the website of the Office
for National Statistics and the Bureau
of Justice of the Americans. And here
you can see these are all the victims
saying who their perpetrators are.
If you care about the dunya more than
the akhira, skip it. By one donation,
you're going to have 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people have been fed
for the emergency food aid. You're going
to be sponsoring 4,200 orphans. You will
be helping 250,000 people in Gaza.
You'll be helping 123,000 people to be
fed through our Qurbani program. You
will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 masajid are going to be built around
the world. And 74,000 given clean safe
water. That's why we want to keep 1 Omar
100% donation policy. And in order for
us to keep 100, we need you to help us
by supporting this fund so that all of
the stuff that I mentioned you get the
reward for every single one of them.
It's far more important than the dunya.
And you will see every penny that you
give on your mawqif ya Omar. The
decision is there. Donate.
>> the moment on Piers Morgan show where
this
dirtbag, Valentina whatever name is, um
who is an immigrant herself, who was
born in Colombia, uh was absolutely
annihilated factually, academically,
intellectually by brother Sammy. Here is
the video. Let's get straight to it,
inshallah. Okay, you obviously didn't
hear me or maybe you didn't understand
it. But just for simplicity, why do you
think it was unfair that you were banned
entry to the United Kingdom?
Piers, because I speak the truth. The
same reason why the Bible is banned in
every Muslim nation. And Piers,
if you come Okay, so
uh
the Bible is banned in every Muslim
nation. What are you on about? There's
Orthodox There's There's There's Coptic
Christians who've lived in Egyptian for
Egypt for hundreds of years, even
thousands of years, probably. Okay. So
you can say absolutely nothing. She's
coming to this march. I hope I hope she
comes. She's been banned. I really hope
she comes cuz I might have a surprise
for her. I'm saying I speak the truth.
I'm saying that I want every rapist and
pedophile behind bars and publicly
executed. I'm saying I want every
terrorist dead. And I'm saying also that
every Muslim should start respecting
Christian nations and maybe hopefully go
back to their 56 Muslim nations, Piers
Morgan.
I mean, I could have the first part I
could not agree even more. She wants all
the pedophiles and child rapists and the
terrorists dead. So, go and take out
Israel, please. Go and take out the
Trump and the elites who were in Epstein
Island raping American girls.
So, they can use that video blackmailing
to blackmail the elite to go to war in
Iran. So, they can send their they use
their little girls, American young girls
and boys girls were used on those
islands so that subhan Allah they can
send their American those very girls
that they raped. So, when they grow up
they can send them to die for Israel.
So, yeah, let's be consistent.
Your reaction when the British Home
Secretary Shabana
Mahmood
banned you from coming in for this rally
because of the incendiary bigoted
comments that you've
been on the record of saying was that
you called her a dirty Pakistani Muslim
and said I'm coming to England on a
boat. Obviously, that is patently
offensive, racist, bigoted and vile. But
also there's a point I'd like to make to
you is that Shab It is this where it
gets really funny guys. Okay, so she's
like she's like immigrant etc. Well, she
was born born in Britain, yes, born and
bred. What about you, Valentino?
>> Shabana Mahmood was born in Birmingham
in England. She's as as English as I am.
You, however, were born in Colombia. You
weren't born in the United States. So, I
would argue that Shabana Mahmood has
much much more validity to be considered
English than you do to be an American.
>> [laughter]
>> Piers Morgan.
Let's see what her comeback is, okay?
Absolutely Oh, you were born in
Colombia. You You want to be She's more
British than you are American. She's
from Pakistan. You're not an actual
British. And let's let's talk about
Pakistan.
She was
>> in the middle of England. Her parents
are from Pakistan. Let's let's not uh
Yeah, she was born in Birmingham in
England. She was born in England. She's
an English
citizen.
>> Her parents are from Pakistan. And and
Piers Morgan, the uh Pakistan is not
known for being the cleanest place on
Earth. It's actually a dirty
full of terrorists. I've never heard
anybody say that they want to go to
Pakistan for vacation.
What an intellectual comeback.
Apparently, Pakistan is a crap hole.
Okay. And nobody has gone there for
holidays.
Wow. Anyways. How many Muslims are there
in the world?
>> They like to rape little girls. That's
nor- That's normal
there.
>> are there? How many Muslims? How many
Muslims?
>> Do Muslims like to rape little girls?
Any evidence? Intellectual, factual,
study, academic, anything? Nope. If
anything, quarter of a million girls
under age are married in America.
And Trump, who is known to have actually
raped these little girls in Epstein
Island, uh for uh you know, used by
Israel and Mossad, that she's being paid
by. So, let's go to now the juiciest
part where she gets annihilated
and goes on and on and on. He's now a
Christian.
>> Piers, it's it's just not true. Piers,
if you don't mind, can I say something
here? Okay.
Piers, if you don't mind, can I say s-
>> Yes, I'll bring in Sammy Hamdi to
respond, yeah. Piers, I just want to She
keeps talking about the idea She keeps
talking about this idea of rapists and
the like. Piers, I went to the uh the
the website of the Office for National
Statistics and the Bureau of Justice of
the Americans. And here you can see
these are all the victims saying who
their perpetrators are. And here they
say that it's people that they know.
It's their family members. It's their
friends. It's their acquaintances. Only
this small number over here is done by a
strangers or what she calls grooming
gangs. You can see the overwhelming
majority are done by those that they
know or those or their relatives. Nobody
says this is white Christian sexual
epidemic. If you look at the population,
she says that they're being taken over.
This is the population of Muslims in the
UK and in the US. In the US 1.1% in the
UK 6%. Tell me, where is the takeover
that's taking place here?
Piers, when you look at the crimes that
are committed against Brits and I'm a
Brit, I'm born and raised here, against
our our sisters and our daughters and
the like. Here are the crimes committed
by Jimmy Savile and Rolf Harris. Nobody
says this is white Christian rape. No
one says this is a white Christian
problem. Everybody says crime has no
faith and it has no race. This was
committed by vile individuals and
justice should be delivered. Piers, when
you look at the Office of National
Statistics and you see the number of
people incarcerated in the UK, you can
see that they are overwhelmingly white.
But nobody says that this country has a
white criminal problem. No one says that
this is a Christian problem. Everybody
says this is a criminal problem by vile
people because crime has no faith and
crime has no race. Piers, when you look
at the mass shootings in America that
killed students and killed their
children. THIS IS THE DATA FROM THE
BUREAU OF JUSTICE IN AMERICA. This is by
white shooters. This is by ethnic
minorities. No one says that in America
they have a She's barking like a dog. No
intellectual argument, nothing. Just
barking like a dog. And she has to put
that little grin. It's not because she
knows. She's She's got nothing to offer.
Wallahi.
>> white Christian shooting problem because
they know crime has no faith. They know
crime has no race and they know that it
is individuals who need to be brought to
justice. The reality is
>> you this question. Sami Hamdi, Sami
Hamdi, Sami Hamdi,
Sami Hamdi, I I understand the point
you're making. It doesn't Okay. So,
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says in the
Quran, when truth comes falsehood
perishes because by its nature,
by its nature, it's going to perish.
When you jump in the water, you are
going to get wet.
By its nature of water, you're going to
get wet. So, Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
says in Surah Mutaffifin that on that
day, the believers will be reclining on
couches, couches, yes? Reclining. And
looking if the disbelievers have been
paid for what they used to do. And the
believers will be laughing. They will be
laughing. Why? Cuz they used to laugh,
mock us out, mock us and, you know, the
volume and oppression that they done.
She does not talk about the Epstein
Islands, what Trump's, you know, has
done, you know, how Mossad has been used
to blackmail, you name it.
Actual American children have been
graped by these vile Zionists. Does not
say a single word. Okay, same with Tommy
Robinson and the far right, which I
might have a surprise for them on May
the 16th myself as well, yours truly,
inshallah. But you see nothing. That's
why on that day, that day is a
graduation day for the believers. Cuz
that day, it's like, you know, when you
graduated and you get your certificate,
on that day the believers will be
rejoicing. It's our graduation day and
we will be looking at them reclining on
sofas for if the disbelievers have been
paid for what they used to do. And we're
talking about disbelievers, we're
talking about vile creatures like this
uh uh person. Would you have allowed her
into the UK?
Here's part of me believes that it would
have been good for Valentina to come and
see the real Britain. The Britain that
belongs to the family that I am in.
>> The English blood that runs through my
kids from Staines and Brighton. It would
have been good for her to come and meet
the wonderful giants of Britain who are
Muslim like Timothy Winter in Cambridge,
like Paul Williams, like Paul Keeler,
like Sohaib Hanif. It would have been
good for her to see the realities of
what Britain is like and how Muslims
live in Britain and contribute to
society. Because when Tucker Carlson
finally saw it, instead of regurgitating
the hate that he was doing to us and
one, Tucker Carlson came
This is key, subhanallah. Tucker Carlson
and Cenk Uygur, how they woke up. But
this woman, look, you can see. She,
look, look, she just it's it's all about
money.
She is like, my lifestyle, I can make
money, popularity.
Look, she might not even believe what
she said. Or even if she does, she's
like, listen, what makes me money?
Hating Islam? Good. Zionists fill my
pocket cuz they fund this Islamophobia
industry.
Let it be." That's what it is. She
genuinely can see there's no
intellectual argument. There's nothing
to be offered here. You can see it's
nothing, but she's like, "You know, I
need to have a nice lifestyle, and that
comes at the cost of You want the
akhirah at the cost of the You want the
dunya at the
at the cost of the akhirah, you are
going to lose both. You're never going
to be happy." We're going to see if she
carries on like this. You're going to
see the end. Depressed, on drugs,
suicide. came out and said I was wrong,
and I didn't know that Muslims love
Jesus, too, and they believe in the
second coming. When Candace finally got
to see the reality, she came out and
said that I was disgusted with myself
for not looking in further. I believe
Valentina is still young. She's in the
early stages of what Tucker Carlson was.
I'm asking her skip the years that it
takes to figure it out. Go and see what
the world looks like. Go and see the
reality because your message of hate
didn't work. Abdul Sayed, the Senate
candidate for Michigan, a right-winger
can see the humility in brother Sami's
uh rational tone. And this is what Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala says in the Quran, "To
call to the way of your Lord with
wisdom, and only that uh repel evil with
that which is good, and if you see and
you will see that the one you have
enmity with, you will see friendship."
And I believe alhamdulillah he's done a
fantastic job. To this vile woman, may
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala guide her or
destroy her. Okay, um nothing much needs
to be said, but here's a video of Tucker
Carlson actually showing how Hezbollah,
if anything, which I'm against Hezbollah
and what they've done to the Sunnis,
they are defending Christians. They are
defending the churches. And it's in our
religion to defend the Christian
churches, the crosses, etc., the monks,
all this kind of stuff, the priests. Our
religion teaches that. Whereas you look
at the Israelis who were hitting the
statue of Jesus,
shooting rockets at the cross in
Bethlehem, if I'm not mistaken, in uh
where Hamas occupied areas, and you can
see who actually cares about the
Christians.
All I have to say is that, brothers and
sisters, inshallah. May Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala guide her, and it's very
important for us to educate ourselves
and make sure these videos go reach far
and wide and intellectually equip
yourself with this knowledge to face and
confront these bigots. Till next time,
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.